you know I feel like you need to talk to
is Joey Diaz I feel like YouTube is a
lot
um except the only difference is like I
don't pull my dick out I didn't sell
Coke that's unfortunate oh I'm low for
two that was him that was him he's a
wild mother he pulled his nuts out on
the uh Comedy Store fundraising live for
the employees yeah for the employees of
The Comedy Store for the staff to raise
money for them during quarantine he
pulled his nuts out it was the greatest
thing I can't stop thinking about it he
is just so lovable and he's the coolest
he lives from his heart you know what I
mean he talks from his heart he's not
sugarcoating it's not sugarcoat and [__]
it's the best thing you know maybe some
of his stuff is uh the more vulgar the
more friends of the best right is that
better he's a real person he's a real
person he's the guy that sell we too
he's just he's lived a life he's been
humble
[Applause]